welcome back to Lawton crime daily in
more celebrity news there are new
developments in the Johnny Depp Saga as
the Pirates of the Caribbean star is
seeking to reverse damages awarded to
ex-wife Amber Heard earlier this year
the celebrity couple battled it out over
defamation claims in court heard wrote
an op-ed in 2018 for the Washington Post
titled I spoke up against sexual
violence Deb argued the op-ed ruined his
reputation while Hurd argued Depp's
legal team made defamatory statements
about her the jury ultimately sided with
Depp awarding him 15 million dollars
despite losing part of her countersuit
the jury awarded her 2 million dollars
for one defamatory statement by Depp's
attorney Adam Waldman now a new appeal
filed by Depp's team wants the judge to
reverse the decision that Depp is on the
hook for that 2 million in this suit the
legal team says quote no evidence of Mr
walderman's actual malice was presented
at trial so the Judgment against Mr Depp
cannot be sustained and that Walden's
words were a quote non-actionable
statement of opinion insufficient to
support a claim of defamation
on the other side of the coin Hurd has
illegal battles of her own involving the
Hefty check to her ex-husband two
insurance companies are fighting over
their financial liability when it comes
to the 15 million dollars payout awarded
to death in a new filing occurs lawyers
want to Halt depositions in that civil
dispute the reasoning is that hers legal
team is currently appealing the trials
outcome and that appeal has not been
ruled on by a judge yet heard's team
also considers their client stateless
she was not living in the U.S when she
was sued by New York Marine one of her
insurance companies saying quote this
court lacks jurisdiction but New York
Marine has publicly disagreed with that
Terry is Depp's argument that he should
not be held liable for what his lawyer
an independent contractor says sound
like a winning argument
me I don't think the lawyer would be
considered an independent contractor in
fact the judge said just the opposite
that the lawyer was the agent and the
legal definition of someone who is an
agent for principal is if you are
authorized to act on behalf of that
principle here the principal would be
deaf obviously so I think the better
argument would have been and they are
arguing this as well that there was not
actual malice there were facts in the
case which demonstrated that the
attorney didn't act with malice and so
it was a mistake but it wasn't with
malice and so I think they could
conceivably win the appeal on that
ground and Malice is that extra element
when talking about public figures so it
makes sense to tack that Bernardo heard
seems to be fighting legal battles on
all fronts where should her Focus be and
can she come out on top
well the deaf heard legal Saga it seems
like it's not going to end any time soon
so while her yes she's trying to fight
on all different levels the ones that
are winning are the attorneys because
they are going to be billing and billing
and billing and getting these attorneys
fees so technically the more the work
they work the more they're going to
increase their fee so that's why they're
fighting so much but in the end I think
that she has to just focus on these
appeals and a hope to get that judgment
lowered or completely vacated but I
doubt that's going to happen well it
makes sense and I would agree there as
well well so what you